this morning we are hearing for the
first time from a close friend of former
miss usa that of course is chelsea chris
chris a former attorney and
entertainment correspondent took her own
life just over a week ago it's still
hard to say that in a statement her
mother revealed that chesley had been
dealing with high functioning depression
which she hid from everyone her family
says she was quote a ball of sunshine
wrapped in smiles
chris friend and publicist is latoya
evans she's also the family spokesperson
she joins us at the table latoya it's
good to see you i was at the airport
over the weekend and there was a picture
of chesley and it still sort of took my
breath away you know it's been eight
days
since she left us when was the last time
you talked to her before she took her
life last sunday friday the friday
before the sun just 48 hours uh she
sounded happy as usual
nothing was amiss
and you know it just who knows the last
time you're going to speak to someone
and she had a big week coming up right
it's not like there was you had no
indication no inkling either i would
imagine you were as stunned as everybody
else true for sure we had meetings
planned for this past week
she had photo shoots dinner with friends
so there again was no indication she had
a packed week she was planning for a
future so it took us all by shock and
surprise her mom called it high
functioning depression most people
aren't familiar with that term
what does that mean
high functioning depression is really
for the overachievers it's for the
people who are celebrated just like
chesley was
and unfortunately taking that pain and
hiding it from others
i uh i work with chesley at extra for
quite some time
and i tried to look back at moments and
i couldn't i couldn't pinpoint anything
but then i started thinking about how
much she was on yeah she never dimmed
like her light was always on
and then i started to think maybe
maybe there was too much pressure for
her to always feel like she had to be on
for everybody else which she did when
she walked in the room she lit it up yes
are there moments when you look back and
you say
maybe i can pinpoint something
honestly i can't there were no signs
because chesley didn't show signs she
purposely concealed those because she
didn't want to burden her family and her
friends just like you said she's someone
who brings joy she brings happiness and
she did that up into her very last
moments i mean hindsight is always 20
20. and unfortunately that's just the
way these things work uh and one of the
things that people are looking at in
hindsight is the allure essay that she
wrote i think you worked on it i did
work with her on the allure essay some
of the lines in it are quite haunting is
she she refers to a lonely craving for
the next award she makes a reference to
turning 30 and running out of time
um when you hear things like that does
that
in retrospect look like a not a cry for
help but a sign of some trouble i really
think it points to the high functioning
depression especially for people who are
in the limelight who are over achievers
they crave the awards they clear they
crave the accolades and that's exactly
what chesley did and i think that that
essay in hindsight speaks to a little
bit of that high-functioning depression
for sure
that can also push you to exhaustion
because you're working so much to get
the admiration from all of these
different spaces and places and she has
worked herself to exhaustion i remember
her talking to me about it and giving me
advice saying nate you need to slow down
because i've been there right um has she
talked to you ever did she ever talk to
you about working too much
i certainly think we've had that
discussion but again for people who are
high functioning for people who are in
the limelight for people who are hard
workers that's relatively normal i keep
thinking about her mom and her
stepfather she was comes from siblings
there were six siblings
and her dad how are they doing i know
you've been in close and constant
contact with the family constant contact
the family is full of grief
um
really it's a shocker so they're still
processing this do they have answers do
you think
i think that you know in the future
they'll certainly reveal more about
high-functioning depression and more
about who chesley was
when they're done with this stage of the
grief process but they are so thankful
for the outpouring of love and support
that people are receiving and giving um
they actually are launching a website
later today called remembering
chesley.com where they just want to
collect all of those stories that we've
been seeing on social media that just
talk about how incredible chesley was
and that's what yeah there have been
some wonderful stories i've got a letter
from a woman who said because of chesley
i was feeling very depressed because of
her i was thinking about taking my own
life and now because of her i'm now
seeking help so she is making a
difference in her death short time here
but she made an impact i get the
impression her family just wants to
grieve at this particular time and wants
to be left alone they do and again
they're so grateful
they're asking still for that respect
for privacy while they grieve this loved
one
but again so grateful thank you latoya
thank you again we really appreciate it
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
national alliance on mental illness
helpline the number there is
1-800-950-6264
we'll put it on our website because i
know it's hard to write it down while
i'm talking in a crisis you can also
text nami to
741-741 we'll be right back